an sehr gutes Abstiegs, man überleider mit einem Verruf geraten.
B-Stol mit ziehen alle B-Forte und schieben den Schirm so über die B-Ebene zusammen.
Das ist der Rollen den Schirm, also der Kampfer, dem voller Z-Flug,
den Stol über, ob geht im sogenannten Sagtflug dann nach unten.
Aber auch wenn man dann mit auch über die Spanweite geöffneten geschoben,
nur über die B-Ebene zusammen geschoben.
Sieht ca. 7 Meter pro Sekund sink.
Was ziemlich gut ist.
Und das Dolan B-Stol, ihr habt praktisch keine körperliche Belastung.
Es ist schon ein bisschen streng am Anfang, aber nachher das halten, das geht eigentlich recht gut.
Aber ihr habt keine körperliche Belastung.
Und darum könnte das auch gut mal über längeren Zeitraum machen.
Da hat er einfach zu viel Belastung für den Körper.
Wer da lust und Bock hat als A-Cop-Bilote, der kann das natürlich machen.
Aber es ist keine effektive, es manöre um für jeden,
für nur lötigen Fals kaputt machen zu können.
B-Stol, dann eben mit dem Bremse einfach locker am Steg in der Hand.
Jetzt, damit uns die B-Guote nicht unabsichtlich rausrutschen,
gehen wir mit den Fingern gespreitzt, zwischen die B-Linen,
oberhalb der Leidenschlösser, und packen diese so symmetrisch,
schön oberhalb der Leidenschlösser.
Und so können uns die B-Guote nicht unabsichtlich entweichen.
Jetzt ist wichtig, machen wir einfach einen langsamen,
aber kräftigen Klimzug dran.
Und diesen halten wir mindestens vier bis fünf Sekunden.
Erst auf mein Kommando Hände hoch.
So, gehen die Hände hoch für die Ausleitung.
Jetzt zeige ich auch, worum die Hände mit nach oben gehen müssen.
Wenn wir einfach aus dieser Position die B-Guote spicken lassen,
, kommen wir vielleicht zusätzlich auf die Bremse.
Das wäre problematisch, wenn wir lassen den B-Stol wieder gehen.
Der Schirm möchte eigentlich anfahren,
ist aber noch ein Moment lang im Sackflug,
und wenn ich dann auf die Bremse gehe,
dann kann ich eigentlich realmente auch die Hände hoch geinten,
um Drückwirtzflug werden.
Und deshalb wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall die gute Schalzen lassen,
sondern wir aktiv nach oben führen.
Das ist schön aus den B-Stol herauskommen.
Bei der Einleitung lassen wir den B-Guote zu sein.
Und diese Kanngriffstellung ist so wichtig.
Auch nicht gerade wieder Schalzen,
wenn wir am Vorpendeln sind.
weil dann würde der Schirm aus dieser Position gerade wieder anfangen und ziemlich gut
beschleunigen können und eventuell sogar zu fest beschleunigen können.
Und deshalb ist es wichtig den B-Stall oder die B-Wur
wurde, mindestens 3 bis 4 Sekunden unten zu behalten.
Also runter ziehen, unten behalten, sodass mir wieder zurück zum unter den Schirm pendeln
können.
Dann wenn wir wieder runter bependen sind, in der Ruhe der Ostlight.